young and old they've come to pay their
respects to former prime minister Shinzo
Abe
gunned down at this very corner of Nara
City just the day before
mourners have laid flowers Beverages and
written tributes thanking Abe for his
service
I thought Abe would continue his efforts
to make the country better my child's
name includes the term Cooney which
represents the beautiful Nation built by
Abe a motorcade carrying Abe's body left
to hospital in Nara his wife akie was
seated in one of the vehicles his body
was brought back to his home in Tokyo
where a crowd of mourners including
friends and colleagues had gathered
who was still a lawmaker in the lower
house had been campaigning in Nara for
the Upper House election on Sunday when
he was gunned down
police say a 41-year-old former Navy
officer has admitted to shooting Abe
telling them he was disgruntled with a
specific organization he believed Abe to
be a part of
the assassination has shocked Japan a
nation with strict gun ownership loss
and low crime rate
Abe Japan's longest serving prime
minister was a highly popular and highly
controversial figure who tried to chart
a bold Way Forward for Japan
economically and diplomatically
a born
strategy thinker
always tried to look Beyond Japan's
Horizon
in order to broaden Japan's diplomatic
in an age when our gigantic neighbor is
growing very much rapidly personally
he is warm and the friendship once
forged
lasts
eternally I'm not exaggerating
he remembers people
once met he wouldn't forget
that's his personal charm tributes have
poured in from around the world the U.N
security Council held a moment of
silence and U.S President Joe Biden has
ordered U.S flags to be flown at half
mast
[Applause]
a night vigil will be held on Monday and
Abe's funeral will take place on Tuesday
to be attended by close friends
Florence Louis Al Jazeera